alongside the furlough scheme for  employees our economic response has also  supported the self-employed 2.3 million  people have now applied for our income  support scheme I know people have been  waiting to hear whether the scheme will  be extended and I understand people have  been anxious I can confirm today the  self-employment income scheme will be  extended with applications opening in  August for a second and final grant the  final grant will work in the same way as  the first aid paid out in a single  installment covering three months worth  of average monthly profits to maintain  the sense of fairness alongside the job  retention scheme the value of the final  grant will be 70 percent up to a total  of six thousand five hundred and seventy  pounds otherwise there will be no  changes and no further extensions to the  schemes which continue to be some of the  most generous in the world